um I'm looking at this they were quiet
about all of this when Sarah Sanders Pam
Bondi secretary Nielsen two republicans
punched one a woman in Minnesota rocks
throw through the door of Kevin
McCarthy's office Ted Cruz Ted Cruz's
wife you see these tactics stand
somebody's gonna get hurt
they even screamed mail bomb we know
where you sleep that is a threat
shouldn't that be isn't that against the
law no absolutely I mean they vandalized
this house Sean I mean this was this was
gross this was disgusting this was uh
this was filthy but Sean you know I have
personal experience with this I've been
in your studio in New York and I've been
in Tucker's in DC many times I've been
on your set with liberals there been
some spicy debates on your sin you know
what happens in the green room everybody
shakes hands says I'll see you the next
time there's got to be a red line here
you know I appreciate some of the
Talking Heads on the Democrat side who
spoke out against this but this has to
be universal Sean I mean when this
pipe-bomb guy recently I was as against
that one because they thought they could
blame that on Trump like the synagogue's
shooting I could blame on tropical
synagogue shooter was anti Trump because
he's pro-israel yes but and the
condemnation was universal on our side
people have to speak out and draw a red
line against us what happened at
Tucker's house last night was an
abomination it was disgusting you know
and let me say there was a report on
media tonight dr. Gork our CNN anchor
apparently is receiving threats no
conservatives we don't want you you're
not a conservative if you're sending
threats to people period it we have no
room for it no now we have over a
conspiracy TV MSNBC they Rachel Maddow
is now encouraging people to go out and
protest today part of a move on or get
effort that's you know general betray us
the same people that you know featured
elderly women vowing to you know private
part punch Mitt Romney and burn this
mother effort down and ads comparing
Bush to Hitler so this is the network
Tom Brokaw is proud of this is that this
person
Maddow claiming she's a news person
really well she's not a news person
Shawn there is a direct line between Jim
Acosta's behavior at that press
conference and what happened at our
friend Tucker's house
these people are repeatedly crossing the
line of what is acceptable whether
you're a reporter in the White House or
whether you're a demonstrator in DC
they're there they're undermining or
they're broadening what is called the
Overton Window meaning the list of
things that are deemed acceptable this
behavior Jim Acosta's behavior or the
behavior at Tucker's house would have
been deemed absolutely unacceptable just
two years ago Maxine Waters it's
throwing up that stock see you're
putting up the addresses right like me
you talker
Ryan Coulter III and I understand you
know I will say another thing here you
know when people look see it at most
what we're called fake news they are
they're not news their opinion well
Larry long said it Larry King said it
when crowds chant they suck that's not
violent or the president says fake news
is the enemy of the people I take that
to mean you're it's a you're performing
a disservice by lying to people
that's all that is then those are words
this is this is a call to action like
Maxine Waters yes this this is the
direct result the vandalism the
intimidation of a woman by herself at
home is the direct result of Maxine
Waters incitement to do this to harass
people who are conservatives and also
Eric Holder the former attorney general
of the Obama administration yeah I have
I'll give you the last word damn I have
a word for conservatives don't kick them
don't get in their faces if you see
people you disagree with don't create
crowds don't follow with people into
stores
leave them alone you know leave them
alone
leave every liberal alone leave every
report early leave every elected
official alone it didn't work out that
well for Republicans in the elec
two midterms where were the Republicans
break in store windows and the Starbucks
and attacking people the answer they
were at work going to work and taking
care of their families take a little
lesson from that in the far left side
Walla tech should work they would dead
silent Pam Bondi Sarah Sanders secretary
Neilson
Ted Cruz Ted Cruz's wife they were
silent now they're actually organizing
it on MSNBC and partnering with
moveon.org
Bush's Hitler pretty discussed
journalism